the league that i would be playing in is  a semi-pro league and what that means is  you are going to school and getting your  master's degree while you're playing for  that school this works out well for a  lot of division three players like me  overseas coaches don't tend to recruit  d3 players  so you can go semi-pro for a year and  then get a pro contract the year after  the problem is that you still have to  pay for school so  i would spend 12 grand on tuition and 12  grand on housing while i'm there i ended  up saving enough at my old job like i  was very frugal  but  part of me wants to invest that into the  youtube channel and building and the  communications platforms that i'm  building instead part of me wants the  experience of living in europe for a  year and playing basketball for a year i  think that would be really fun